Traduttore: Isabelle Andrieu
Revisore: Michele Gianella
La blockchain decentralizzata.
Ma scusi, questo lo sanno tutti,
è scritto su tutti i giornali.
È un database organizzato in blocchi
che sono leggibili da tutti,
tutti possono scrivere un piccolo [dato]
in qualche pagina di questo blocco,
e non è alterabile da nessuno.
Nessuno può alterare
il contenuto dei blocchi
né l'ordine dei blocchi.
E diciamo, la promessa che questa
tecnologia avrà per l'umanità -
Chi più ne ha, più ne metta,
perché sono praticamente illimitate.
Chi è che non apprezza
l'inalterabilità di un database?
Chi non apprezza la trasparenza?
Chi non apprezza la capacità
di generare fiducia
tra persone che appena si conoscono?
Quindi perché parlarne?
Perché ci sono dei "ma",
e i "ma" sono praticamente
tre domande fondamentali.
Questo, a testa e croce,
questo registro condiviso, in realtà,
come si fa a definirlo?
E avendolo definito,
come si fa a implementarlo?
E poi, alla fine, perché ci serve?
Dunque, cominciamo dalla prima domanda.
Dal "cosa".
Cos'è una blockchain decentralizzata?
Innanzitutto bisogna definire e capire.
Avete mai visto uno zoologo che classifica
gli animali in base a quante zampe hanno?
Certo, ci sono i bipedi, i tripodi,
i quadrupedi, i centipedi.
No. Né dal colore che hanno. E perché no?
Perché queste sono
caratteristiche non essenziali.
Perché alla fine gli animali,
a differenza dei minerali, sono vivi;
e forse, classificarli in base
a come si riproducono,
e quindi danno la vita,
è più significativo
che non il colore della pelliccia.
Benissimo, e allora cos'è
una blockchain decentralizzata?
Spesso i regolatori e altri dicono:
"Beh, si misura dal numero di utenti".
Più utenti hai e più sei decentralizzato.
Be', se io fossi un imperatore
con milioni di sudditi
sono forse meno decentralizzato? No.
Oppure dal numero di nodi?
No. E perché no?
Per lo stesso motivo di prima.
Queste non sono
caratteristiche essenziali.
Allora cos'è che è essenziale?
Essenziale nella blockchain
è scegliere il prossimo blocco.
Perché i blocchi consistono
di tutte le transazioni che sono avvenute.
Se non stanno in blockchain
non sono mai avvenute,
e se fossi io a scegliere
il prossimo blocco, direi:
"Queste transazioni
verranno scritte nel mondo
e queste altre non le voglio scrivere".
Avrei un potere più assoluto
di quello di Luigi XIV,
quindi forse il monarca
assoluto per eccellenza.
Quindi cominciamo a concentrarci sul fatto
che è la partecipazione
alla generazione dei blocchi
che rende decentralizzata una blockchain.
Qualunque cosa avete visto e sentito,
da ora in poi vi esorto
a seguire questa pista.
Benissimo. Avendo già una dritta su quella
che è una blockchain decentralizzata,
come si fa a farla?
Diciamo che non è facilissimo,
perché la blockchain è un prodotto
squisitamente tecnologico,
e quindi senza tecnologia
non si va da nessuna parte.
Almeno in blockchain.
E perché è difficile?
Perché fino a pochi mesi fa
vigeva il famoso trilemma
che diceva che se volete una blockchain,
dovete scegliere al più due
di queste tre proprietà:
la decentralizzazione,
la sicurezza e la scalabilità.
Immaginiamoci che disastro
se questo fosse vero,
perché io sono "Blockchain by design",
voi siete un cliente e vi dico:
"Benvenuto alla Blockchain by design,
volete una blockchain?"
- "Certo!" - "Ve ne do una
per voi, insicura!"
"No, veramente
me ne servirebbe una sicura."
"Allora ve ne do una non scalabile."
"Mica mi serve per giocare
con parenti e amici.
Io voglio una cosa scalabile."
E alla fin fine, chi sacrifichiamo?
Bingo! La decentralizzazione.
E infatti,
fortunatamente è stato così,
ma questo trilemma è falso.
La verità è appunto che invece
la grandissima maggioranza
delle tecnologie blockchain
non garantiscono la decentralizzazione.
Qui ci sono varie tecnologie
di cui avete sentito parlare,
ne parleremo brevemente: proof of work,
delegated proof of stake.
Di decentralizzazione non se ne parla.
Non se ne vede neanche l'ombra.
Allora vediamo perché.
Proof of work. Questa è
una grande idea, è la prima idea.
Tanto di cappello al signor
o alla signora Nakamoto,
o i Nakamoto, non so quanti siano,
i quali hanno inventato
questa proof of work,
che consiste in questo:
non sono io a scegliere la proof of work,
non sei neanche tu.
Facciamo così.
Generiamo un indovinello
matematico difficilissimo.
Il primo che lo risolve porta la soluzione
e ha il diritto di attaccarla
alla blockchain.
Rimane un sistema democratico.
Benissimo.
Purtroppo, è estremamente lento,
perché per essere sicuri
che non ci sono due soluzioni
a pochi secondi l'uno dall'altro,
questo indovinello
deve essere così difficile
che in quanti milioni di persone
provano a risolverlo,
ce ne deve essere una ogni tanto.
Altrimenti non sappiamo, nella blockchain,
se la chain va di qua o va di là.
Perché ci sarebbe una fork.
È costoso perché a questo punto
non so se avete visto,
fate: "Google, miner. Blockchain miner",
e troverete un'immagine
di migliaia e migliaia e migliaia
di computer super specializzati
che servono solo
a migliorare la probabilità
che sia tu a scegliere il prossimo blocco.
Il sistema è talmente costoso
e che cosa succede
quando le cose diventano troppo costose?
Che ce ne sono uno, due, tre
che se lo possono permettere.
Per esempio, la catena Bitcoin,
forse la più famosa catena,
è controllata da tre mine pool.
Ora ditemi voi se una catena
controllata da tre enti
è centralizzata o decentralizzata.
A me pare molto centralizzata.
E se ciò non bastasse,
l'inquinamento generato
da tutti questi computer
è pazzesco.
Questi consumano -
Originariamente consumavano
più energia elettrica del Lichtenstein,
poi del Massachusetts, poi della Svizzera.
Insomma le cose crescono.
Peggio di così...
La prossima tecnologia,
Delegated proof of stake.
Semplicissima!
Infatti, voglio dire, quasi banale.
Scegliamo. Vedete quelle 21 persone lì?
Non sono oneste?
Sì che lo sembrano!
E io credo anche che continueranno
ad essere oneste,
per cui diamo loro il mandato
di scegliere il prossimo blocco
per tutti noi. Grazie e arrivederci.
Allora... Diciamo, questo è...
...la Proof of work partiva da un'idea,
c'era questo indovinello
che potevamo risolvere tutti,
e via via, alla fin fine
è diventata centralizzata,
ma questa era centralizzata?
È centralizzata
e rimarrà centralizzata per sempre,
perché non è il modo giusto
di fare le cose.
Non voglio perdere tempo
con altre proprietà.
Basti dire che tutti questi approcci
partivano da una logica fasulla.
E la logica è questa:
l'economia totale è sicura
se la maggioranza di un pezzettino
di questa economia è onesta.
Scusa, non ho capito bene.
Certo che non hai capito,
perché non ha senso.
Immaginiamo, appunto,
qui c'è tutta l'economia.
Vedete quel pezzettino lì?
Sono quelli che se sono onesti
tutto funziona,
altrimenti andiamo tutti in malora.
E cos'è questo pezzettino verde?
Nella Proof of work
sono questi tre minatori.
Nella Delegated Proof of Stake,
sono i 22 membri scelti chissà come.
E diciamo questo qui non va bene.
E allora di cosa c'è bisogno?
Non bisogna disperare.
Una volta che abbiamo inquadrato
il problema,
io sono sempre ottimista
sull'ingegno umano,
e poi in generale sulla tecnologia.
La tecnologia dice
che dobbiamo, semplicemente,
cambiare completamente l'approccio.
Voltiamo pagina.
Ed ecco invece...
Questo, che io credo abbia
le caratteristiche che vogliamo,
è la Proof of stake pura.
Cosa vuol dire? Vuol dire questo.
Qui ci sono, come voi sapete, in Bitcoin
ed altri, questi Tokens, i famosi Tokens.
Ogni Token ha lo stesso potere
di generare un blocco.
E diciamo, tutti questi Token,
queste monete, però dove stanno?
Stanno nel portafogli,
pronte ad essere spese,
investite nelle varie possibilità
che ci dà la blockchain.
E se la maggioranza delle monete,
in tutto il sistema, è in mani oneste,
il sistema è sicuro.
Soffermiamoci sulla terza cosa.
Cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che non sono
tre minatori che decidono:
"Se mi va, distruggo la blockchain".
Deve essere la maggioranza di quelli
che possiedono le monete del sistema,
la maggioranza dell'economia,
devono decidere di coalizzarsi,
coordinarsi l'uno con l'altro
e spararsi sul piede
per distruggere quella stessa economia
di cui possiedono la maggioranza.
Forse ci penseranno
due volte, prima di farlo.
E la generazione dei blocchi come avviene?
Semplicissimo.
Nella generazione di blocchi,
ogni blocco viene generato da un comitato.
Chi sono questi membri del comitato?
Si scelgono a caso mille monete:
queste monete, scelte a caso,
apparterranno a qualcuno;
costoro sono i membri del loro comitato.
E quel comitato sceglierà un loro blocco.
E il prossimo blocco? Un altro comitato!
Si scelgono altre 1.000 monete a caso,
i possessori formano un comitato
che genera il blocco.
E una volta scelto, che devo fare?
Se fossi scelto.
Se una delle mie monete fosse scelta
e io faccio parte del comitato?
Devo mandare in rete un piccolo messaggio
facile da ricalcolare.
Quindi da qui vedete
come si venerano i blocchi.
Però, dico, grazie, Silvio,
di questa visione dall'alto
della pura Proof of Stake.
Ma chi è che sceglie
questi benedetti comitati?
Certo, non io, altrimenti
sarebbe centralizzatissima.
Nessuno li sceglie. Si auto-scelgono.
Come? Si auto-scelgono?
Questa forse è la peggiore idea
che io abbia mai sentito,
perché, se io sono un disonesto,
e mi posso auto-scegliere,
certamente che mi scelgo
per essere membro di questo comitato
e scegliere questo blocco.
Anzi, mi auto-scelgo
pure per il prossimo blocco
e cosa faccio?
Per induzione mi scelgo pure,
così sto sempre a scegliere i blocchi.
Però, non così semplice.
Cosa vuol dire auto scegliersi?
Vuol dire che avete una bella
"slot-machine crittografica", ok?
C'è questa famosa leva.
Metti i soldi, spingi la leva,
o vinci o perdi.
Questa slot machine,
essendo crittografica,
non posso barare.
Posso alzare la leva una sola volta
e posso vincere o perdere.
Se vinco, ottengo una prova,
un biglietto vincente.
Una prova della mia vittoria,
della mia vincita,
e quindi cosa faccio?
"Ecco il mio biglietto vincente!"
Essendo una prova,
tutti lo possono verificare.
Ed ecco la mia opinione sul block.
Più o meno va così.
Fatemi dire perché questo
è decentralizzato.
Perché giustamente ogni volta
c'è una lotteria diversa.
Voi abbassate, o si vince o si perde.
Ogni moneta fa la sua propria lotteria.
Come se avesse una manina
che abbassa la leva.
Se voi possedete più monete,
forse avete più possibilità di vincere.
E certamente sono 1.000 monete
sparse in tutto il mondo,
decentralizzato lo è.
Più decentralizzato di così
forse non si può.
Perché è scalabile?
Quanto tempo ci vuole
ad abbassare questa leva?
Un microsecondo.
E una volta abbassato? Lo ricordate?
Mandiamo in onda il biglietto vincente,
e la vostra opinione sul blocco.
Quindi questo è facile da fare.
E adesso diciamo perché è super sicuro.
Supponiamo che io sia un personaggio
tanto malevolo quanto potente.
Posso corrompere istantaneamente
mille persone in tutto il mondo
allo schioccare delle dita.
Chi voglio corrompere?
I membri del comitato.
Però, c'è un problema:
Chi devo corrompere?
Perché voi state abbassando
le vostre leve.
Che ne so chi ha vinto?
Devo corrompere te, o te,
o quest'altra signora a Shanghai?
Non ne ho nessuna idea.
Però una volta che gli auto-scelti,
quelli con il biglietto vincente,
dicono: "Ecco il mio biglietto vincente,
ecco la mia opinione sul blocco",
li conosco tutti e posso corromperli
istantaneamente.
Però che ci ho fatto?
Quello che dovevano dire
l'hanno già detto.
Il loro biglietto vincente,
la loro opinione nel blocco
si sta propagando viralmente nel network
e non posso rimetterlo nella bottiglia
né più né meno che qualunque governo
possa mettere nella bottiglia
un messaggio di Wikileaks
che pure si propaga viralmente.
Quindi il sistema è sicuro
perché inizialmente non so chi corrompere,
e dopo è troppo tardi per corrompere.
Quindi questo ci dà -
al di là della blockchain,
è uno strumento
per potere davvero progredire
in modo democratico in tutto il mondo,
mantenendo il mondo decentralizzato.
E come vedete questo trilemma famoso,
facendo le cose un po' poco ortodosse,
si riesce ad ottenere quelle che prima
era considerato impossibile.
Di cose impossibili nella vita ce ne sono:
fortunatamente, ce ne sono molto poche.
Perché spesso l'impossibile è risolvibile.
Ma perché la vogliamo,
questa blockchain decentralizzata?
Perché la decentralizzazione
è una fonte di sicurezza enorme,
perché più partecipanti
ci sono al sistema,
più difficile è corrompere il sistema.
Se tutto è centralizzato,
metto una bomba atomica su di uno
e ho finito, la blockchain è sparita.
Quando invece è talmente capillare
che tutti i possessori
di una moneta nel mondo
possono essere capaci
di generare il blocco,
è difficile attaccare il sistema.
Un altro motivo
è che questo è un modo
non soltanto di garantire
la sicurezza della rete,
perché ricordiamoci che la blockchain
è un gioco di comunicazione.
E questo protocollo di comunicazione
si svolge su una rete, Internet.
Quindi non soltanto
uno può attaccare il protocollo,
ma anche può, all'antica,
tagliare fili e riprogrammare i router,
e tutti i sistemi precedenti,
riprogrammando i router o tagliando fili,
riuscivano a distruggere la sicurezza
quand'anche fossero tutti onesti.
Quindi non è una buona cosa.
Questa è una sicurezza ulteriore,
quella che vogliamo.
E poi, come dicevo prima,
la decentralizzazione vera
garantisce disintermediazione
senza frodi e senza costi.
E quindi garantisce -
Tutti abbiamo il desiderio di interoperare
gli uni con gli altri, di interagire.
Se lo potessimo fare con sicurezza
anche con le persone che non conosciamo
mi sembra che sia un bel dono all'umanità.
Questo dono viene dalla tecnologia.
Io sono un tecnologo, lo chiarisco:
però mi pare che la tecnologia
sia profondamente umana.
Da quando siamo scesi dagli alberi
e abbiamo costruito il primo strumento,
viviamo meglio
e siamo forse diventati più umani
di quanto eravamo prima.
Non toglie nulla all'Umanesimo,
è un'aggiunta.
E diciamo anche che il mondo
si rende molto più complicato,
per molte - ma non tutte -
delle nostre aspirazioni
la misura in cui riusciamo a raggiungerle
dipenderà dalla bontà della tecnologia
che siamo riusciti a costruire.
Una cosa però.
Come in tutto, ci vuole tanto amore
e tanta forza di volontà.
E però noi abbiamo
qualcosa di meglio da fare
di cercare di raggiungere
le nostre aspirazioni?
Io non credo, per cui, diciamo,
meritiamoci la nostra tecnologia
e godiamocela quanto più possibile.
(Applausi)